هذا هو القدر وفي حال كان المشرف عليه
رجلا فالاكيد ان الطبقه الذي يعد هو
المنسف التحضيرات على قدم وساق فالمتعه
تبدا مع بدايه مراحل تحظيره وصولا لذه
تناوله اكله تحمل من التاريخ ما اهلها
لدخول عالم الشهره وادراجها ضمن قائمه
التراث العالمي
ليست اكله الاباء والاجداد فقط ف دراسات
اكدت ان المنسف حاضرا منذ سبعه الاف عامه
تناوله الاردنيون القدماء وتورثته الاجيال
بحبه دلالات تاريخيه واخرى تعنى بالعادات
والتقاليد فان حضر المنسف له وجود لاي طبق
اخر كعنوان للمناسباتها حاضر بالافراح
والاطراح والعزائم وحتى لما الاهل
والاصحاب
مرتبط بالمكان الاردني والجغرافيا
الاردنيه
وايضا هذا المنسف اصبح له حضوره انه عابر
للمكان والزمان
واستوعب كل الحضارات التي مرت في التاريخ
الاردني مضامين ثقافيه يحملها المنسف خاصه
بطريقه تناوله واحترام الضيف وتكريمه
فالوقوف حوله لتناوله يروي الكثيره عن كرم
الاردنيين وتاريخهم وان كانت بساطه
مكوناته واضحه لبن اساسه الجميل احد اهم
اسرار نكهته اضافه لللحم والخبز او الارز
الا ان الكثير من الاعراف المرتبطه
بتقديمه تحتاج لتفسير والشرح هذا الطبق
تاريخ تاريخ الطقوس اللي وصلنا لها
والاخلاقيه اللي وصلنا لها انا بعتقد
مرتبطه بسلوك اجتماعي مستمر عبر مئات
المسلمين انت تزور الاردن دون تناول
المنسف فهذا مستحيل طبق يعد هويه ثقافيه
للشعب حافظ عليه منذ لا في السنين حتى
استطاع المنسف وبجداره التميز عن باقي
الاطباق التقليديه الاردنيه
طبق اردني وصل للعالميه وادرج على قائمه
التراث العالمي غير المادي لليونسكو عماد
العضيلي العربيه عمان